i
can't believe that this is not a
saturday night live schedule i guess the
way i know that this is not a saturday
night live sketch is that this is funny
we have
a
twice failed
democrat from texas now announcing a
third one he ran for senate and lost
he ran for president and really lost
and now what happens when you lose twice
you run a third time for a completely
different office ladies and gentlemen i
give you beto for governor of texas
i'm running for governor and i want to
tell you why
this past february when the electricity
grid failed and millions of our fellow
texans were without power which meant
that the lights wouldn't turn on the
heat wouldn't run and pretty soon their
pipes froze and the water stopped
flowing they were abandoned by those who
were elected to serve and look out for
them
it's a symptom of a much larger problem
that we have in texas right now
those in positions of public trust have
stopped listening to
serving and paying attention to and
trusting the people of texas and so
they're not focused on the things that
we really want them to do like making
sure that we have a functioning
electricity grid or that we're creating
the best jobs in america right here in
texas or that we have world-class
schools or that we make progress on the
things that most of us actually agree on
like expanding medicaid or legalizing
marijuana
so guys i
look bros i just i just really want to
be a politician all right i'm just going
to put my cards on the he this guy is
more matthew mcconaughey than matthew
mcconaughey you know people said matthew
mcconaughey is going to run for governor
he sort of is it's just it's like
matthew mcconaughey without the
intelligence or virtue or charisma then
you get beto o'rourke and so he's
running because he just really wants to
be a politician
and it's very easy to make fun of beto
he is probably the most easily mockable
politician
alive
i'm trying to think of one who's
someone said that beto is like the
democrat jeb not even close jeb is like
alexander the great compared to beto
o'rourke okay
jeb is charlemagne compared to beto
o'rourke but
well we can mock him as a skateboarding
dude bro whiny millennial
kerouac reading
joke
loser
i wouldn't count him out
i wouldn't i wouldn't i'm urging caution
do not
do not count beto out he's a joke
whose high point of his presidential
campaign was when he said hell yeah i'm
going to take your ar-15s yeah yeah man
yeah yeah wouldn't it be cool what if
the color that you see as green i see as
blue you know he's just like his lines
just come out of freshman philosophy
seminars
but persistence can pay off
okay we talked about this yesterday on
the show the power of persistence
democrats are nothing if not persistent
john ossoff ran for congress in georgia
he was a joke he was a very silly
candidate that the democrats and
especially people in hollywood dumped
about a bazillion dollars into and then
he lost and we all laughed at him and he
even looked like beto and he kind of
talked like beto and you know what what
he is now he's senator ossoff because he
lost he loses loses loses loses until he
wins right he's just they are just
persistent
stacey abrams loses the georgia
governor's race if you asked a lot of
people in georgia right now who's the
governor they would probably tell you
stacey abrams
because she's so persistent she keeps
she tried to be vice president
i'm sure she's going to run again she's
going to run for a million other offices
until she wins
richard nixon actually he's one of ours
who did this
richard nixon would have the
presidential race stolen from him in
1960 and he keeps running runs runs runs
runs runs and then he wins
do not count out pers it's not it's not
enough for republicans to just pass the
law
get the
decision from the judge
sign the executive order and then say
we've solved it no you've got to keep up
that
persistence i can't believe we have to
learn anything from beta or work but we
might you you you hold on hold on
thank you for stopping by i'm glad you
watched that clip
if you wouldn't mind ring that bell
subscribe you will get notifications and
if our overlords on the big tech
platforms don't give you notifications i
would strongly recommend you head on
over to apple podcasts spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast subscribe to the michael knowles
show maybe leave a five-star review if
you want to make me feel good
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you